in order to establish this unique
community we have to focus on this
type of dna okay entrepreneurs and to
integrate themselves yeah and then
and the second uh
a world we actually once we came to
define what will be our kpi
we decided
our main kpi
is to make sure that those startups will
be successful
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders until now
we've had quite a few israeli
entrepreneurs and investors from the
startup nation well today we're going to
dig a little bit deeper and look at the
startup nation from a different lens
meet offi
an active prolific technology investor
in israel ophir is the ceo founder board
member and was previously a corporate
manager
he served as the ceo of several startups
and until mid 2015 when he turned his
vision to expand the startup nation
boundaries into his full-time job by
founding open value a chain of
innovation centers in the northern part
of israel with over 150 startups
open valley also established an academy
of entrepreneurship and innovation which
supports various organizations
corporates ngos governments and
municipalities army units school chains
and more to implement entrepreneurship
tools and methods within their
organizations
it's a pleasure having here talking
about extending the boundary of the
startup nation uh you know there's so
many so much talk about the start of
nation and innovation or everything
that's happening in between yet you're
taking a
a just as an important approach and
looking more closely what the startup
nation actually means and and looking at
where there's perhaps opportunities that
are missed people that
may
have the ability to be part of the sort
of nation but perhaps due to
geographical barriers they're currently
not a part of this amazing ecosystems
and
so with open valley you're doing exactly
that but but your previous journey is
just fascinating a director within mdocs
chief operating officer of nye systems
and so and then an entrepreneur for
quite a few years and so fear i'm
excited to chat with you in these 20
minutes and hear a little bit about your
journey and your thesis here
okay so let's start with a with a short
break from by myself
[Music]
actually i grew up in the north in the
northern part of israel in haifa um
i graduated high school and back in 89
and joined the army and
after that i worked very hard in order
to complete my industrial management
engineering um and i started my career
uh at the late 90s um
in you know
back then it was it was a high-tech moon
uh it was just uh previous to the 2000 i
worked for
uh a company specialized with software
testing by the name of tesco doesn't
exist anymore back then it was quite
a large player in this in this field
so i spent quite a few years over there
and gained a lot of experience mainly
and in managing account
and uh
2001 i relocated with my with my wife i
was just i was just got married and we
relocated to london
um
and
back then i managed the operation of
this this company in europe
uh
i was based in in the uk
and uh
i uh complete my executive mba in
the london school for me it was a
combined program with the anonymous
economy and nyu
um
it was fascinating i i i you know
expanding my network i got to know many
uh you know interesting people around
the world
um
2000 and
in late 2003 we got back to israel
and i joined undocks and i got the
opportunity to be part of the team we
established a division
and
from scratch and it was it was a big
success i was specialized in
exception testing
and this was uh the main business of the
of the si division at amdax
um later on i was actually enhanced and
enjoying a nice system and
johnny became ceo of part of the
operation at nice and back then nice and
quite few few companies
so i was
i was traveling a lot i really ireland
um and in late 2007 i uh
i joined with two
friends of mine back from high school
and uh
and
we came up with idea uh related to a
data storage business
um
we uh draw a presentation of 20 slides
and a
very interesting idea back then it was a
power digital shift in the in the
storage business and we
raised money from leading venture
capitals amongst them supplier capital
tango rob spain and others well
quite a bit quite an experience
yeah yeah and it was it was a roller
coaster like any any startup and we were
under still smooth for
three years and the company grew very
fast
and um
and fast forward in late 2012 as a
changing investor joining i
did my personal
transaction and then in late 2012 i
find myself
you know in in my prime time
looking for something interesting to do
and
before that i
moved
with my family from the central part of
israel from la mata chavon and we built
the house in a small beautiful village
at the jezreel valley
and israel
and
a beautiful place called
the reason we did that is because then
my my wife and myself we want to
give our children um
you know a different environment a
different kind of education in different
environment be be
closer to the to the ground to the soil
and um
in moving back to the late 2012 i
decided back then that i would like to
bring my experience my knowledge
and also my capabilities to support
early-stage entrepreneurs with their
journey
so i did something back then that was
very natural i commute on a daily basis
from my small village in the jesuit
valley and mckislin
and you know two televisions why to tell
reveal again because back then
approximately
93 percent of startups were based on a
periphery of
kilometers in between
celebi dwarf and the watcher bull board
okay 90 percent of startups in israel at
any given time them between
12 000 to 15 000
and
this is you know the ecosystem for
startups so i i did it quite naturally
on once and and daily basis and 10 12
meetings
every day you know meetings in the in
the cafe places
but after six seven months doing so and
i did quite a few uh of course uh
contacts and investments that's an angel
in investor
but after after doing so on a daily
basis i i really i really got tired
because you know the commute was you
know became became impossible
uh after after every week
uh you know dude
uh you know traffic and traffic jams and
public sales
transportation so i just want to make
sure that i'm recapping correctly where
we are until this point so so you
you find yourself you know your london
business school with nyu you find
yourself in the center of the of the
israeli ecosystem you find yourself with
with some of the most interesting
companies that are playing a pivotal
role in the israel ecosystem like mdocs
like nice systems in leadership
positions so the chief operating officer
of nice and then uh then creating a
company which is uh you know every
entrepreneur's dream led with investment
rounds led by some of the most
phenomenal funds in the world like
sequoia so you really are living
sort of this the entrepreneurial
experience and we're talking also at a
time with the proliferation of of of the
entrepreneurial scene in the startup
nation
and then you and then when you when you
leave the company after about five years
you decide to
with your family you're moving to
um to a different part of israel which
is a little calmer it's not where the
startup nation
is it's not where it's centralized you
want because you want it you wanted
different
perhaps different life qualities for the
for your kids whether it be connection
to the soil education et cetera but
you're finding ways to mitigate your
professional life which is which is in
between tel aviv and herzelia and your
personal life which is in
israel and then you start understanding
that okay i if i'm away i can't really
participate in this eco chamber because
i it's just that it just doesn't work
and so i need to find a solution for
that
yeah in my in my view you know everyone
calls as you know a startup nation but
in my experience it was it's actually
startup city
okay yeah and for me that was it was an
oxymoron meaning
you know people like myself and there
are tens of thousand people who are you
know who decide to come and build their
houses and educate their kids in this
part of the country but at the same time
if they would like to become
an entrepreneur
they they need you know to commute
and this is you know the
acquisition the
the balance so
so for me it was it was
at some point i asked myself and back
then it was like a science fiction a
question
how come the startups that will be
established in the jews will bowling
will be less successful comparing to
startups that actually establish in the
watching will work or okay yeah another
place to live
and for that and and at some point i uh
i'm going back to my story i i i changed
my you know my new linkedin you know my
uh
you know they know that the fact that
i'm i'm meeting people only on my in my
backyard in you know the small village
valley
so i i i continuing um conducting those
meetings with eddie's agent panels but i
did it you know and at my home
so um entrepreneurs who are looking for
you know for funding they will commute
anywhere but the facts that i set
in at my home i was actually i was
exposed war and water
to entrepreneurs from the northern part
of israel generally specifically from
the jesuit body
and and i realized at some point those
one you know
we lived you know in
the northern part of israel and managed
to
to gather seed money by my support or or
by other uh
people
support
and once they they they weather and seed
money they
they thought okay so now we need to
consider you know what future ones so we
need to do the you know to the vcs we
need to uh to recruit talent so they did
uh again they took the car and drove to
tel aviv and we already do stuff
so
right so you're saying that we we had
sort of a solution but but it was
short-lived because all it did was delay
the inevitable of having to move to the
more centralized location you're just
delaying that decision making process
and and for me it was really hurting i
mean
i
then i realized that you know the main
reason they that they are
actually the arms
and you know the real community for
startups in this part of israel is the
fact that we are letting an ecosystem
for that okay and let's talk about
ecosystem
how come tel aviv became one of the
leading ecosystem you know for
entrepreneurial startups and ecosystem
actually uh you know uh
derived and uh
built for various entities right
among them you know obviously
the financial players okay the pcs and
the banks uh
service providers um
you know academy
and government municipals
and and all in all it's about to network
it okay how you how you connect between
those entities
and put them together and you know to
the startups
you know
a community and find you know the uh
the you know the win-win between those
entities and in the startups and this is
exactly exactly what i started to do
back then with group people we
we started to establish a community and
meet on a monthly basis for for meetups
you know in the area
and then for each and every um a meet up
we
i am i invited the entrepreneur you know
to talk about the success about the
failures and people they came and they
talk about their idea and look for
co-founder and look for feedbacks like
like what you do in any other event but
but the community start to establishing
for
one meetings to another there were more
and more people joining eventually
hundreds of hundreds of people all you
know from all over the area came
in order to to participate in those
meetups so i realized
you know that there was enough in our
talents and a world material in this
area in order to act and move to the
next stage
and
at this point i decided i would like to
take it you know
one step further and to establish a
place
that will be and that will gather of all
of those entrepreneurs and support them
you know with the with endeavor of
establishing the only sr
but i realize that
you know that for that we need
you know we need to invest a lot i will
need to you know to put the contacts in
and build the ecosystem so
i i i
i look for a co-founder you know as
someone that can help me and support me
uh you know with this
with this uh dream okay with this vision
and not so we showed i was lucky enough
you know to knock on the door of a of
a veteran in the israeli industry in the
market
and he leaves the village just leaves a
village across mining atletico madrid
and his name is jose akerman jose akaman
is
he's a tour leader and he was the ceo
and president of albert systems for
almost 20 years and
he made elbit a leading player in you
know in its field and for many years he
was recognized as the
as the most admired the ceo in israel
and he's really a unique person and i
knocked on his door i didn't know he
possibly just knew about him and
i got his friends you know his contact
and i did a call call and he came and
talked to him
and
i was very you know excited and i came
with my pitch and after two sentences
about my dream news has taught me
instead of fear i'm in
i'm in because i'm really uh i feel the
same way i really feel that we need
to create this type of community here uh
i see all of the young people and you
know all of the
entrepreneurs and they running and you
know tel aviv in order to establish
their own problems
so let's start to do some impact around
here and you'll see
yeah you know
the north of israel and the jezreel
valley always always was very important
for him he
you know throughout his
career he developed you know the
northern part of israel with alberta
you know facilities and factories and
offices all over
and um
in january 2016 we established our first
branch of open valley
in ramatishai which is in the heart of
the tesla valley
and we decided um
two main uh
let's say um
walls for us first of all
that the inhabitant of open value we
will be entrepreneurs and startups open
valley is not a real estate business
okay
unlike the any you know other very known
uh co-working spaces that are mainly
based on real estate
open valley house of entrepreneurs and
startups okay and at the beginning and
many you know uh
businesses knocked on our door and
asked for a small office but we we
really
insisted to both only depends the
startups and we made a lot of research
and i personally uh i
commute all of the nodes in order to
collect them and bring them to
openvolume
and
and just so that i mean why
why have that barrier why not allow
others to join not the
companies that are maybe aren't early
stage startups because uh
we realize that in order for us to
establish
a community fluentable with startups we
really need to
you know to gather them together all
kinds of startups by the way uh
and we're dealing with entrepreneurship
okay and uh not necessarily
technological although the most of our
uh you know startups and today we have
more than 150 startups you know in our
chain are
basically uh technologically startups
but to realize that in order to
establish this unique community we have
to focus on this
type of dna okay entrepreneurs into
antibiotics and startups yeah and then
and the second
and we we actually once we came to
define what will be our kpi
we decided
our main kpi
is to make sure that those startups will
be successful that's mean
our mindset our efforts our contact our
networking
and also i our money were
you know at focus uh toward
toward uh
you know those startups
um
so we
we sit down with them we
you know uh we supported them with with
them with all you know the main
activities and
board meetings and
and we start to look for investments for
ourselves
and throughout the time once we we
establish more and more branches after
romantic shy we establish a very large
branch in
zarya and caesarea
and later in in yokonian and just
recently in ramata golan
and in few months uh hopefully we'll
establish our first location south to
tel aviv in this dude and we have made
him uh potentially a location so for us
you know it was it was mainly
a focus to establish the ecosystem but
but by putting together those entities
that i mentioned together with with the
startups and support them and
not only with funding from us and others
but but also with with uh you know
expanding and
open themselves to markets to uh
potential customers
and they
you know all kinds they
support the startup actually
incredible well the the natural next
step is to
is too hopeful to have an institutional
fund because you you're seeing them on
the day to day and you can
follow them for months and day and be a
leading and be a leading
investor in the ecosystem of anything
outside of the tel aviv slay area which
other vcs don't have the you know they
just don't have that interaction today
so it it sounds like a it sounds like an
amazing natural progression but beyond
that it sounds like you're
you're very fulfilled yeah with what you
do
with the mission that you're on what the
journey is actually you know open valley
is not an ngo it's a we are an ltd
company where we're based on economic
business rules and uh
and and while the time and you know this
is part of our evolution
we uh we build few layers to our
business so so we do have you know the
layout of uh
like any other co-op in space of the
real estate art but but the top of it we
we also establish an academy for
innovation and
entrepreneurship because once we put
together you know the ecosystem around
us with startups the ecosystem around us
which means you know the industry the
corporates
the government municipals you know ngos
came and approached us and asked our and
ask our support
to help them to develop their own
entrepreneurship
you know any any ceo today uh
and it doesn't matter if it's technology
and you know based on technology or
or
a traditional industry or ngo or a
military unit or a or a government
office
you know they they they really uh
and considering
how they will be down the road in you
know three four years and they say they
will be innovative so
we've been asked by by the ecosystem
around us to develop you know and to
help them to develop and
entrepreneurship you know tools
within the organization it's open valley
four or five years ago established an
academy for innovation so we supported
the
both corporates government municipals
and defense and also high schools all
around israel together with the oath you
know old high school chain in it in
lunch and many other we developed a
program with six years a program for
high schools and you know a
student
uh for uh you know for entrepreneurship
and innovation and and all of that
in all of this you know i consider part
of establishing the ecosystem because
once we support our ecosystem to
becoming innovative
um so
at the end of the day uh we are changing
you know when we're impacting our our
surrounding and we put uh together all
the time the contacts between our
startups and industry it's very very
important for them
and we do scouting for many uh
corporates and they put them in touch
with startups among you know a open
valley so our day-to-day is is that is
mainly uh how to
establish develop and you know the
ecosystem and surrounding the places
that we you know we we decide to invest
well
i think that um what i love more most
about this this
journey is that it the way that it
impacted you personally the the personal
convictions you've had and how you it
sounds like you were discovering sort of
this product market fit between
what you're what you're excited about
and then having an actual impact on an
ecosystem and you really are creating
communities and that that need to be
there and
and and i'm curious to see how over the
years we'll see
the centralization of the of television
earthly adapting to this to to
all these new ecosystems whether they'll
be you know different ecosystems whether
they'll be integrated as a part of the
startup nation or whether it may be
their own startup scenes in a you know
with a new world where geographical
limits are are less a little bit less
relevant
i think that you know maybe you can even
equate it to something like
um you know palo alto silicon valley and
austin texas right sort of like a
similar idea where you're creating these
new centralized hubs of innovation where
they obviously work together you have
perhaps even offices in both locations
but you realize that people want to have
different forms of life and different
ways of life
and so it's a very interesting question
and of fear i really want to thank you
for coming here and sharing this journey
with me i i love the transitions and the
personal convictions and the
the unapologetic nature of how you're
going about this and and thinking
through these issues so thank you very
much continue making a really positive
impact on on so many people and i i'm
sure that
all these startups are so thankful to
have this space and
and that you really are changing the
landscape wherever you are so thank you
and best of luck
it was a real pleasure and i hope you'll
come to visit us next time your name is
though
100 day well thank you very much
[Music]
you